night, anxiety, this noise, this broken glass, we
understood what we are, what we are
now just some Eternity
breathing on the back of my head
I started to shoe the children very quickly, I
put someone in winter shoes What kind of sweater
was in the corridor, then I started to put them on as I ran,
the house shuddered, it was some kind of
earthquake
The house just
groaned,
we all probably jumped up, the children started
screaming madly,
I looked at Their faces, I didn't know
which of them I should remember,
I didn't know Who, well, which of them I
might not see anymore, we
understood that the house had arrived at our house
we met the third arrival on the grass when she
shouted to lie down and we were all just children who
hit our knees because they just
fell at that moment and they were already on the ground
and this explosive wave I didn't feel it, my
husband felt it
I just lay in that black soil with my face in
that grass, and I also did not know
at all whether I would raise my face from that
earth or whether my children would become from it or whether we are still a
family. Whether we are or we no longer have a family, I did
not know this, it is also like the sky, the moon, a
huge church.  my park is my
family my home and I am completely powerless that
is, this car is already carrying this wave is carrying
me
and
what a happiness it was to hear their frightened
voices
I hope for a miracle I
believe in it I
don't know what kind of miracle it will be but I know that
it will happen. I think it's just that
so much pain has already
been poured in here
and that we have already suffered so much as a
nation
that simply all the supreme powers must
intervene, we have already proven to everyone what
we can do, what we are capable of